wir sagen es reicht uns macht endlich
aufgibt uns unser normales leben zurück
warum weigern sie sich das zu tun ist
zunächst einmal also ist das vollkommen
verständlich dass die bürger jetzt
endlich also in die normalität zurück
wollen das ist absolut verständlich ist
anlegen und dem so widmen wir uns ja
auch aber man muss überlegen passt das
jetzt also wir haben ja jetzt in die
mikrowelle hinein
reformen gemacht die gut geklappt haben
wir haben eine gute also sterblichkeit
im vergleich zu anderen ländern wir
haben also relativ
moderate fallzahlen im vergleich zu dem
was sonst gewesen wäre das heißt die
strategie die wir gefahren haben klappt
im großen und ganzen wir sind aber noch
nicht über den berg hinweg und wieso
sollten wir was derzeit gut klappt was
uns schon ein paar hundert menschenleben
oder mehr gerettet hat wieso sollten wir
das wenige also wochen bevor wir die
welle gebrochen haben viel zu früh lockt
aber unicom ist wesentlich
ungefährlicher als man gesagt hat es
gibt weniger hospitalisierungen weniger
tote dadurch gleichzeitig sehen wir beim
cupid index der uni oxford dass
deutschland weltweit die strengsten
maßnahmen hat ist das wirklich etwas
worauf ich stolz sein sollten die
fallzahlen sind nicht so hoch wie sonst
wären ohne die massnahmen und ich sterbe
zahlen sind auch nicht so hoch wenn man
jetzt zum beispiel also auf deutschland
übertragen würde die sterbezahlen mit
omikron was ja nicht so schwer verläuft
wie data warnt und so alles gut aber
wenn man das jetzt vergleichen würde
sagen ja was wäre denn in deutschland
werden wir so vorgehen würden wie in
england zum beispiel dann hätten wir pro
tag über den daumen gepeilt vielleicht
300 tote am tag und wir haben aber
deutlich weniger waren vielleicht 60 bis
80 durch und das ist der unterschied
zwischen einer seiner restriktiven
politik und einer sachsen wenn ich einen
satz zu sagen darf wir schützen wirklich
mit den maßnahmen dass die
mikrowelle die älteren menschen und die
besonders gefährdeten in dem maße
erreicht wie das sonst der fall wäre
damit retten wir jeden tag leben sie
sagen wir jeden tag leben gleichzeitig
gibt es erhebliche folgeschäden
psychische schäden bei kindern und
jugendlichen viele menschen die angst
vor der pleite haben wir sehen das
kinder- und jugendpsychiatrie volllaufen
dazu möchte ich ihnen einmal zeigen was
unsere zuschauerinnen liegt länger zu
sagen hat herr lauterbach jetzt stehe
ich vor ihnen und habe die frage wie
geht es ihnen wenn sie abends ins bett
gehen können sie ruhig schlafen oder
haben wir ein schlechtes gewissen haben
sie im blick dass neben der körperlichen
gesundheit natürlich auch die seelische
gesundheit
eine große rolle spielt und ist die in
gefahr wenn sie so viele west case
szenarien uns immer wieder vor augen
mein ja seine ganz berechtigte frage man
darf nicht mit worst case szenarien aber
was tun sie ja ja das stimmt nicht also
das was sie malen immer wieder aus wie
dramatisch aber es ist dann haben sie
auf ihr aber das sei twitter twittern
sie jeden tag neue studienjahr aber
schlimm dass wir noch schlimmer aber
alles ganz dramatisch nein ist es nicht
also es stimmt einfach schlicht so gar
nicht das kann ich ja auch nicht stehen
lassen so das verfestigt sich ja das
sind also sagen wir das ist ein wenn ich
will nicht zu nahe treten aber das ist
eigentlich nichts anderes als also was
sie es vorgetragen haben was wir alles
also dramatisch und soweit vortage das
geschoben ich bin orientiere mich im
großen und ganzen an dem modell des
robert-koch-instituts ben meyer der
brockmann und wir fahren gezielt mit
diesem modell schon seit der zweiten
januarwoche fahren wir die maßnahmen und
das hat im großen ganzen auch geklappt
wir versuchen daher maßvoll reinzugehen
und wenn ich mich auch aber es wohl eher
nicht maßvoll wenn weltweit wie die
strenge maßnahmen haben wenn um uns
herum die maßnahmen fallen wenn alle auf
machen und sie weiter sagen nein das
bleibt so wir haben also im maßnahmen
die im verhältnis zu den maßnahmen die
richtige harte drakonischen maßnahmen
gewesen sind beispielsweise harte
lockdown maßnahmen haben wir die haben
wir selbst in der ersten welle nicht
ergriffen also man da jetzt sind wir in
ja aber weiter jahre oder auch weil er
laut nicht mehr über die vergangenheit
der nähe aber länger hat ja gesagt die
folgeschäden bei kinder und jugendliche
psychisch
natürlich würde ich es mir wünschen dass
also die bundesländer und es gibt hier
große unterschiede
dass es den bundesländern die für die
schulpolitik zuständig sind zum teil
besser gelingen würde die schulen vor
schweren also infektionswellen die wir
zum tatort beobachten was ja auch die
eltern dann trifft besser zu beschützen
das würde ich mir wünschen mit länder
unterscheiden sich da zum teil aber ich
will einfach klar noch mal sagen ich bin
nicht zuständig für die schulpolitik das
ist nicht also das kann ich nicht also
darauf habe ich keinen direkten einfluss
was wir machen können dass wir zum
beispiel regeln geben wie lange müssen
kinder in quarantäne und das haben wir
zum beispiel für kurz da empfehlen wir
im gegensatz zu erwachsenen fünf tage um
die kinder möglichst schnell wieder in
die schule zu bringen aber man muss auch
offen sein also die also die maßnahmen
die wir ergriffen haben die jetzt am
wirken sind das sind im wesentlichen
maßnahmen die die sterblichkeit
reduzieren und wir appellieren an die
länder so viel zu machen damit die
kinder in der schule bleiben können ohne
infektion wie möglich die freibier
zuschauern war ja auch haben sie
eigentlich ein schlechtes gewissen
angesichts dieser folgeschäden die ja
dann auch durch ihre politik entstehen
nämlich dass viele kinder und
jugendliche depressiv werden das ist
große probleme gibt bei menschen die
eben selbstständig sind all diese dinge
diese folge stehen da hat man in
deutschland auf das gefühl dass sie da
eine politik an den tag legen die sich
eben ausschließlich auf corona tote
kroner fälle fokussiert nein das ist
natürlich nicht so unsere corona politik
und das ja nicht nur meine politik aber
ich stehe für diese politik drum ich
auch heute hier
diese politik hat es natürlich wie jeder
andere ärztliche maßnahme nebenwirkungen
und gegners kennt das also wenn sie eine
also gefährliche situation managen wall
für den patienten müssen sie
nebenwirkungen in kauf nehmen wir
versuchen wirklich diese nebenwirkungen
so gering zu halten wie irgend geht dazu
zählt auch zum beispiel dass wir
angebote schaffen für eine also also für
eine psychotherapeutische betreuung wir
haben also diverse programme am platz wo
sich menschen wenden können da diese die
deutsche kinder- und jugendpsychiatrie
sind überlastet sie sagen aber die
krankenhäuser sind überlastet aber real
erleben wir dass ein kinder- und
jugendpsychiater lauf ich sage es mal so
wenn man einräumt dass es nebenwirkungen
gibt dann stimmt das und das tut mir
sehr leid also bin selbst also vater
einer teenager tochter kenne das ganz
genau aber die nebenwirkungen müssen so
gering sein wie geht was ich nicht gut
finde
wo ich ein problem habe ist wenn dann
das leid des einen gegen das leid des
anderen aus spielt das finde ich nicht
gut spaltet die gesellschaft
wir müssen so viel wir können tun um
unsere kinder in der schule zu warten
ich habe dazu in der in der
vergangenheit immer wieder vorschläge
gemacht auch für die länder ich habe
hier schon gesessen da habe ich über
luftfilter anlagen und doziert und
gebeten dass er mehr passieren muss und
so weiter so aber wir versuchen wirklich
die nebenwirkungen so gering zu halten
wie geht und also das aber ohne
nebenwirkung geht das hier nicht ab das
war es wieder hast ich will ihn einmal
zeigen wir stefan mielchen zu sagen hat
auch ein zuschauer von bild herr
lauterbach haben sie eine idee wie lang
der ganze scheiß noch dauert
das ist eine sehr kurze frage und die
schnelle antwort ist die also ich glaube
nicht dass die letzte variante die
omikron variante ist ich habe mich da
ziemlich tief in die literatur ein
gearbeitet und bin auch mit
wissenschaftlern in kontakt die also
davon leben dass zu analysieren wie
verändern sich das wie verändert sich
das virus und daher wir werden mehr
varianten noch bekommen dafür sie ist
auch noch so viel unterwegs also es gibt
so viel veränderung sehen da selbst die
omikron variante hat sich jetzt
verändert also in einer doch schon
relativ weit in baa2 also in einer
relativ kurzen zeit noch mal deutlich
verändert wir sehen veränderung bei
anderen varianten das heißt das wird
nicht zu ende sein mit omikron wer meint
ja die maßnahmen da so die maßnahmen die
schachtel gesagt haben mach ich glaube
der scheiß war er bezogen auf masten
pflicht 2 g.de 2g plus all diese dinge
die immer noch da sein und in anderen
ländern wechselt er hat ist also ehrlich
gesagt also die frage also ich bin nicht
bereit das was wir hier tun
um menschenleben zu retten und schwerer
krankheit zu
verhindern und also longo wie zu
verhindern unsere gesellschaft also vor
schwersten langfrist folgen zu schützen
ich bin nicht bereit das also also als
chance zu diskutieren
dennoch haben viele zuschriften uns
erreicht insbesondere in verbindung mit
ihrer person und der frage was für eine
politik in deutschland gemacht wird und
einige zuschauer machen ihnen den
vorwurf dass sie zitat durch angstmache
populär geworden seien und deshalb am
ende gar kein interesse daran hätten
dass die maßnahmen zurückgefahren werden
das ist jetzt eine weitere fragen danach
kommt aber der vorwurf der von vielen
kam und auch bei twitter man ihn immer
wieder ließ dass sie durch angstmache
populär geworden seien und deswegen kein
interesse daran hätten dass die
maßnahmen zurückgefahren werden ja das
ist auch ehrlich gesagt also geschwurbel
ich mache aber kann man wirklich immer
alles mit geschwurbel angestellt ist
aber diese zwei dinge also wenn jemand
sagt dass die maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen mit denen wir so viele
menschen geschützt haben vor schwerster
krankheit und vertont wenn man diese
maßnahmen abgeformt als scheiß dann ist
das aus jetzt geht es um den vorwurf
dass ich wir haben ja komm jetzt dazu
habe sie ja sagen ich hätte alles also
ausgeschrieben ab da ich mir nochmal auf
die aussagen davor war ich ja ich bin
ein bisschen bestürzt auch schon gesagt
dass so etwas überhaupt eingeblendete
dabei ist egal
geschenk der bei uns können die
zuschauer ja aber die meinung vertreten
die sie haben uns allen wichtig genau
aber dann bekommen sie auch eine klare
sollen an bord bleiben da bekommen sie
eine ganz klare antwort auch die bleibe
ich nicht schuldig und jetzt jetzt also
ich arbeite nicht mit angst sondern ich
arbeite schlichten ergreifen mit der
darstellung wo wir derzeit sind auf der
grundlage der wissenschaftlichen studien
oder der modelle beispielsweise und das
wird von vielen sogar auch als befreiend
also bisher geschwiegen als verängstigen
empfunden wenn wir zum beispiel also
darauf hinweisen dass also wir mit
impfungen drei mal geimpft eine
grundimmunisierung so erreichen können
die vor weiteren varianten
wahrscheinlich so gut schützt das also
wir
als gesellschaft sehr gut geschützt sein
werden das ist eine maßnahme die macht
ja nicht angst sondern sagen lösungs
schlüssel aber es ist wohl die anderen
zum beispiel markus söder die jetzt auch
sagen wie viele zuschauer wir müssen
jetzt langsam mal öffnen es ja ich
glaube trotzdem also ich bringe ständig
lösungen ich habe zum beispiel dafür
gesorgt dass wir paket eines der besten
medikamente eine million dosen gekauft
haben also wir haben impfstoff besorgt
die booster kampagne läuft ich versuche
tatsächlich dass ich auch meine aufgabe
konkret also die situation zu bewältigen
und die bewertungen wo wir derzeit
stehen nehmen wir ja im verbund vor
robert koch-institut expertenrat ich
selbst da stehen wir zusammen und das
ist eine beschreiben wo er derzeit sind
ich nehme zur kenntnis dass also jetzt
im politischen umfeld also der wunsch
nach lockerungen nicht nur der
natürlichen umfeld kann ich ihnen sagen
herr lauterbach ja dass ich halte das
noch mal hoch was die forderung von bild
ist
ja bei allem respekt vorbild aber also
bild hatakka sie keine
außerparlamentarischen sonderrechte die
hier durchgesetzt werden müssen somit
das nämlich zur kenntnis das ist aber
mich für mich noch nicht
handlungsleitend da muss mehr kommen als
eine schlagzeile aus dass ich mich
bewegt nicht nur eine schlagzeile
sondern auch eine reaktion darauf die
wir immer wieder hören von unseren
leserinnen und lesern von unseren
zuschauern und die große frage die sich
viele nämlich stellen was muss denn dann
passieren wenn sie dagegen sind bis die
kriterien fall da hat man nur selten
eine frage zu
und möchte wissen was sind die genauen
kriterien die gegeben sein müssen damit
alle maßnahmen und einschränkungen
wegfallen hier ist es eingeblendet
können sie diese kriterien genau
formuliert nein die kann man zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht genau
definieren die also es kommt ja darauf
an wie man auch machen will für eine
rückfahrt prophylaxe das heißt also was
jetzt erst mal für mich im vordergrund
steht dass wir diese mikrowelle also
brechen dass die fallzahlen stark
zurückgehen dann können wir die
maßnahmen mit denen wir die mikrowelle
beherrscht haben können wir dann
zurücknehmen weitestgehend und dann
gehen wir weiter dann muss man aber
schauen was es insgesamt lage wie hoch
ist die impfquote ich kann immer nur
sagen also der größte
bremse für
wirklich maßgebliche und auch
langfristige locken sind die umkämpften
wenn es die umkämpften nicht gäbe dann
also könnten wir uns was lockerungen
angeht natürlich sehr viel mehr leisten
man darf nicht vergessen wir schützen
hier das gesundheitssystem vor
überforderung und wieso müssen wir das
gesundheitssystem vor überforderung
schützen weil es so viele ungeimpfte
gibt die davon sonst außer nicht wie
viel gibt's denn genau können sie uns
das sagen das ist ja das problem mit dem
datenklau und nicht die genesende mit
einbringen nicht nicht immer sofort
chaos also daten also es gibt
unsicherheiten oder sagen wir
unsicherheiten bei den daten aber so
schlimm ist es nicht wir gehen davon aus
dass bei den über 60-jährigen dass die
wichtigste gruppe 12 prozent nicht
geimpft sind und das ist eine sehr hohe
zahl und das gibt dann darüber nach
hinaus bei denen also jüngeren auch noch
fehle der risikofaktoren haben die auch
um games sind aber die hauptsorge machen
uns wirklich die zwölf prozent über 60
jährige und das hat england natürlich
eine ganz andere situation ich bin eben
sie haben ja auch angesprochen also
england lockert jetzt und also gehen
sehr viel weiter na ja da geht man davon
aus dass bei den über 60-jährigen nur
zwei prozent nicht geimpft sind oder
genesen aber bei uns kann man das ja
nicht mal sagen das ist ja das große
problem sowieso kann man das nicht sagen
weil die daten die wir haben am ende
nicht vergleichbar sind mit denen in
england naja ich glaube ich auch
vorsichtig also es gibt ja die daten des
robert koch institut ist die also
ausweisen wie viele impfungen sind
gemacht worden und die entsprechen
ungefähr dem auf was in der praxis dann
sehen ich will ihnen einmal zeigen was
michael na wollt wissen will der sagt
nämlich warum lassen wir es mit omikron
nicht einfach laufen andere länder tun
es doch auch in die krankenhäuser kommen
doch deswegen nicht mehr menschen als
bei anderen krankheiten ich kenne auch
fälle wo ungeimpfte keine symptome
hatten also dass man wegen denen nicht
lockert ist für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar ja es entspricht eben
nicht im wissen dazwischen sachstand das
ist zum beispiel nicht die position
unseres expertenrats also die diese
strategie wenn man das an die stadt
laufen lassen eine strategie zu nennen
ist ein bisschen bemüht aber sagen wir
lassen das jetzt durch gehen und sagen
das ist eine strategie wir lassen es
einfach laufen das lehnte expertenrat ab
dass lebenden die wissenschaftler ab die
uns sonst beraten das wird uns aus dem
ausland auch nicht geraten bei der hohen
zahl der ungeimpften ich könnte es
selbst auch nicht vertreten oder wieder
als minister noch so als wissenschaftler
weil wir hätten dann innerhalb von
kurzer zeit hätten wir hat schwer
schwere fälle das ist einfach so wir
sehen dass zum beispiel in frankreich da
gibt es auch noch ungeahnte dennoch
nicht bis in alle ewigkeit
wir sind jetzt in berlin ja dieser panne
während sich ja gar nicht immer noch in
die welle wird ja jetzt gebrochen ich
habe ja schon also in der zweiten
januarwoche habe ich gesagt dass wir den
höhepunkt mitte februar mit der
mikrowelle erwarten können das kann sich
also noch ein bisschen den zähnen wegen
ba2 das glaube ich aber nicht aber wir
sind wirklich vor dem höhepunkt der
welle dann gehen die fallzahlen deutlich
runter und dann kann man auch sehr gut
locker und vornehmen also das ist jetzt
wir sind jetzt quasi im dritten jahr der
pandemie auf dem haben noch nicht sagen
gehabt und also in das maximum der
fallzahlen hinein jetzt zu lockern das
bedeutet hat ich glaube öl ins feuer
dann bleiben wir bei der frage der
lockerung denn das ist das was die
menschen momentan mit am meisten bewegt
csu-chef söder noch einmal hat gesagt
wir brauchen konsequente öffnung
schritte in ein zwei wochen fdp-chef
lindner fordert bundesweite abschaffung
aller zweig regeln für den handel nach
dem vorbild von schleswig-holstein und
eine strategie für öffnung schritte ja
das werden wir alles am 16 diskutieren
was ist da ihre position ich will hier
der also diskussion die wir in der
gruppe haben nicht vorweg greifen
das wird sich nicht gehören also ich
glaube dass wir tatsächlich diese
debatte haben werden sind sie für
lockerungen oder dagegen das kommt doch
waren wie die fahrt zahlen sich jetzt
entwickeln jetzt im moment bin ich
dagegen das habe ich ja auch also heute
noch mal in ihrem blatt klar gesagt weil
ich hatte es für verrückt wenn man bei
höchstzahlen so von infizierten und
einer guten strategie die funktioniert
wir haben also wie deutlich weniger
sterbefälle als andere länder weil die
also die abschottung der älter und
risikofaktoren funktioniert wieso soll
ich bei höchstzahlen von infizierten an
einer funktionierenden strategie dann
lockern die frage ist ja ob diese
strategie funktioniert wir haben über
folgeschäden schon gesprochen und über
das was das mit deutschland macht was es
mit den kindern und jugendlichen macht
was ist mit unserem land macht dass wir
einfach weiter so machen wie vorher dass
die anderen um uns herum öffnen und wir
weiterhin bei diesen strikten kurs
bleiben sie können sagen sie
konzentrieren sich allein darauf was es
für tote was es für fälle bei krone
bedeutet aber die gesamtlage ist ja
völlig undurchschaubar nächsten show
durchschaubar wir haben ja
rettungspakete am platz also und wir
flankieren ja das was wir derzeit machen
mit erheblichen wirtschaftspolitischen
maßnahmen sie müssen einräumen dass wir
im vergleich zu anderen ländern die es
lockerer genommen haben gut auch
wirtschaftlich durch die krise bisher
gekommen sind also aber die begründung
für die maßnahme war ja immer dass eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystem
verhindert werden muss und wenn man sich
das anschaut gibt es jetzt noch die
gefahr dass intensivstation volllaufen
und kollabieren und wie wahrscheinlich
ist das warum ist das in der mikrowelle
denn in keinem anderen land passieren
und sie waren weiter davon wir haben hat
im vergleich zu anderen ländern haben
wir hat die hohe zahl ungeimpfte älterer
menschen das ist ganz einfach so also
wenn ich das jetzt so laufen lassen dann
so werden dann dann explodieren die
fallzahlen und dann sind sie halt
betroffenen menschen gehen davon aus
dass immer noch eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystem droht das zeigen die
modelle ganz klar also wenn wir es jetzt
laut werden wir das jetzt komplett
öffnen würden ja und also es ist ein
unterschied ob ich jetzt hier etwas
schätze oder uns war das wort sondern
die modelle die bisher die letzten
wochen sehr gut vorhergesagt haben
welche quellen dass der richter gleich
hat darum gebeten dass die auch also bei
also auf der homepage des robert koch
instituts veröffentlicht werden eben
dieses modell bernd meyer der borgmann
das ein modell wenn arbeiten auch mit
einem anderen modell noch von viola
prise man aber das modell von meyer und
braucht man das heißt relativ gut
vorhergesagt was auf den also an den
fahrzeugen zu sehen ist und also an den
auf den intensivstationen und das gibt
dem keinen grund zur entwarnung und
daher hat der expertenrat persönlich
empfohlen ich will ihn einmal zeigen was
ein wird viele tonka zu der situation zu
sagen hat
2g so wie es aussieht ist es irgendwie
nutzt nichts besser dass die ganze
aufwand meinetwegen dass die leute mit
den schutzmaske rein und raus kommen
weil sowieso nicht viel los meiner
meinung nach der zweig oder zweig plus
bringt eigentlich nichts mehr
das war jetzt ein gastwirt oder naja der
gas würde das ja von 2g plus betroffen
und werden wir das nicht gemacht hätten
zweig plus gehört zu den maßnahmen die
wirklich dazu geführt haben dass wir
also ganz so far zahl wir haben noch
immer eine instanz 1400 das ist nicht so
firm grund ist das sehr gut also wenn
wir das jetzt nicht gemacht hätten und
nicht am platz hätten dann könnten wir
dieses instruments hat nicht halten aber
warum haben wir die
zweijährigen im handel nicht sofort auf
den geimpften und genießen können
omikron genauso wie nicht die impfte
übertragen das ist nicht ganz so also
erstens also ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie sich überhaupt mit omikron
infizieren wenn sie geimpft sind viel
geringer
sie müssen deutlich unterscheiden werden
sich aufgrund haben ob es dann genauso
ansteckend ist was auch noch falsch ist
aber lassen wir das mal geschenkt aber
die es was die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
sie es bekommen geringer wenn sie also
geimpft sind und wenn sie es dann
bekommen also infizieren sie
wahrscheinlich auch weniger leute
dennoch es gibt so viele logik probleme
in der ganzen sache nehmen wir das
beispiel schlussrunde was ist denn
gefährlicher wenn gäste fünf minuten
nach 22 uhr oder 24 uhr da sind wir
können sperrstunden dazu beitragen
corona nicht zu verbraucher können jetzt
durch jede einzelne maßnahme gehen und
die absurdum führen zum beispiel zehn
leute dürfen sich treffen aber nicht wo
ist denn da der unterschied aber ist ja
wichtig für viele menschen da hängen
existenzen tatsachen wie handelte also
man muss wenn man alle maßnahmen danach
die funktionieren soll dann muss man ja
irgendwo einen also
schnittpunkte aber er erscheint für
viele nicht mehr logisch noch ein
beispiel warum dürfen menschen in
innenräumen konzerte bei konzerten sein
und in bundesliga stadien ist die
zuschauerzahl immer noch maximal niedrig
das also sind dinge die angepasst werden
in der tat aber also die also bei den
bundesligaspielen war ja immer das
problem nicht dass die menschen draußen
beim spiel dann sagen wir mit abstand
sitzen sondern wie kommen sie hin und da
war das hauptrisiko dass sie sozusagen
in straßenbahnen bussen und den autos
dann zum stadion fahren und sich bei
dieser gelegenheit infizieren das ist
der springende punkt und jetzt gibt es
natürlich also beispielsweise stadien
wie bayern münchen sie sagen sie haben
das größte stadion in europa jeder
parkhaus in europa und also jeder kannte
als den anfang und das muss man immer
prüfen indem sie das wird ja auch
gemacht wir prüfen ja diese regeln und
ich kämpfe ja hier nicht also um eine
einzelne regel wenn wir wenn hier einer
etwas geändert aus ihrer sicht zahlen wo
sagen sie da reicht auch mir das
persönlich bei ihnen lautet ich bin da
sie sagen da habe ich keinen bock mehr
drauf bin da ich bin ja komplett kollege
in dem sinne also wir besprechen das
also egal für sonntags-
ministerkonferenz bei der mpk wir
besprechen das im kabinett ich bin ein
komplett
solidarischer kollege das heißt über ich
über falle die leute jetzt nicht mit
denen ich das bei später entwickeln muss
mit öffentlichen vorschlägen so sehr ich
ihre frage da versteht sondern ich halte
quasi mein pulver trocken wir werden
zusammen also das ist also ist der
lindner unkollegial nein das ist er
nicht hat ja nur gesagt dass wir in
diese richtung denken müssen und das ist
erstens richtig da also sehe ich genau
sagt aber die konkreten vorschläge
müssten dann ja zu diskutieren seien
deswegen will ich ja konkrete vorschläge
und irgendein lena hat einen vorschlag
gemacht herr söder hat auch ein
vorschlag gemacht in schleswig holstein
sagt man auch zwei gehweg also was ist
ihre idee hier können die vorschläge
kommen dann nachher auf den tisch aber
ich muss nachher schauen das ist meine
aufgabe dass das so sammer
maßnahmenbündel was also doch noch
bleibt dass das wirklich reicht um gut
durch diese welle noch so komm ich will
einfach mit möglichst wenig sterbefälle
nebenwirkung schwersten verlassen
übrigens auch bei den kindern also ich
habe mich eben über diese
gegenüberstellung auch die kinder leiden
unter omikron sehr starke wenn möchte
auch bei den kindern möchte ich nicht so
viele fälle haben auch das dass wir
jetzt am ende dieses sei mal heftigen
winters die kinder im stich lassen und
nassen da ne welle durch oppeln wie
nichts das ist ja gar nicht richtig also
wenn ich sie so höre habe ich das gefühl
ich stehe da er auf der seite von den
kretschmann in baden-württemberg der
sarg vor ostern nicht lockern
herrn kann ich mal habe ich mich nicht
ausgetauscht ich glaube dass wir vor
deutlich vor ostern lockern werden davon
bin ich fest überzeugt aber ich arbeite
einfach gerne
mit wissenschaftlichen daten und wir
haben aber was heißt deutlich vor ostern
herr lauterbach es kommt darauf an wenn
es so ist wir haben ja gesagt mitte
januar werde sagt mitte februar ist die
der höhepunkt der welle und dann gehen
die fallzahlen deutlich runter wenn das
tatsächlich klappt wenn wir hinkommen
sehen die fallzahlen gehen runter und es
ist gelungen
also einen großen teil der bevölkerung
zu schützen vor schwerer krankheit oder
foto das man dann in die lockerungen
über geht das ganz klar aber also
erstens muss man erst mal darf das fell
des bären nicht
verteilen bevor er erschossen ist und
wie lockerung am 16 das wird dann sind
wir wahrscheinlich noch miteinander
wurde aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass wir über lockerungen diskutieren ob
das tatsächlich zu lockerungen kommt das
hängt davon ab wo wir dann stehen nach
der werbung herr lauterbach wollen wir
über das impfen sprechen und darüber wie
es mir passieren konnte trotz booster
ein zweites mal angesteckt zu werden
gleich nach der werbung
herzlich willkommen zurück bei die
richtigen fragen heute abend mit
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach erlaubt aber vorhin sitzt
jemand der gepustet ist aber sich zum
zweiten mal angesteckt hat und ich hatte
das immer so im ohr sie und andere haben
erzählt dass das auch gegen die
ansteckung sehr gut hilft müssen sie
sich da korrigieren und sagen die
impfung hilft eben nicht so sehr gegen
die ansteckung ich kenne mittlerweile
menschen die sich dreimal angesteckt
haben nein muss ich nicht korrigieren
hat er nicht also da der booster impfung
ist es so dass der schutz vor oregon
dann bei 70 bis 80 prozent liegt aber da
bleiben natürlich 20 bis 30 prozent
übrig wenn man jetzt also gar nicht
games wäre oder zweimal gegeben sondern
wer das risiko deutlich höher in dem
sinne somit also ist derjenige der trotz
booster impfung also die omikron
infektion bekommt der hat pech weil er
zu den 20 bis 30 prozent gehört die
nicht beschützt also nicht gewirkt hat
von denjenigen die sich also haben wir
die exponiert gewesen und hätte nicht
dass der eindruck entsteht 30 prozent
der geimpften bekennt dass es wieder was
anderes und zum zweiten sie haben wie
man sieht einen also kommoden verlauf
gehabt und wenn wir ihn vielleicht sonst
nicht gegönnt gewesen ohne die impfung
dennoch frage ich mich jetzt wie oft
müssen wir uns noch impfen lassen erst
hieß es zwei dann war von dreien die
rede der berühmte booster schott und
jetzt hört man plötzlich dass es sogar
vier geben soll zumindest für bestimmte
gruppen sie haben im januar noch gesagt
mitte januar drei reichen werden wir uns
ewig impfen 6 7 8 9 10 mal was wollen
sie von den menschen zunächst ich will
gar nicht von den menschen sondern ich
gebe nur ratschläge und so möchte nichts
sondern also erklären wie die stadt der
wissenschaft ist und was wir politisch
machen und na ja sie wollen ja schon was
wenn sie daneben pflicht beschließen
keine ahnung wie eine ferne genau für
eine also impfpflicht oder eine
grundimmunisierung der bevölkerung
reichen drei impfungen das ist also
relativ gut belegt damit ist die zahl
der antikörper aber auch insbesondere
die anderen formen der also immunabwehr
die sind damit so stark angeregt dass
man damit also einen wirklich sehr
schweren verlauf bis auf ausnahmen also
keine vierte info der vierte impfung
macht nur sinn bei hochrisiko menschen
also bei denjenigen also die andere
erkrankungen haben immunerkrankungen
haben da ist dann auch der um der
impfschutz mit drei impfungen zum teil
gar nicht komplett gewesen das sind aber
sehr wenige und die betrüger die
allgemeinheit geben aus ihrer sicht was
man als ich ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
was die wissenschaftliche literatur
angeht eine vierte impfung für die
allgemeinheit nicht sinnvoll ist das
versprechen also wissenschaftler
versprechen nichts sondern beschreiben
wo derzeit der studienstart ist unter
derzeitige stunden studien stand das ich
kann nur versprechen dass ich den gut
kenne das kann ich ihnen definitiv
versprechen und der derzeitige studien
stand spricht klar gegen eine vierte
impfung für die allgemeinheit das haben
wir der vergangenheit schon ein paar mal
erlebt der lauterbach dass sich das
verändert aber da werden sie auch immer
wieder um verständnis dass sich die
studienlage ändern von daher muss ich
sagen habe ich da noch nicht so viel
vertrauen dass am ende die vierte fünfte
sechste nicht kommt aber christopher hat
was interessantes eine interessante
frage christian drosten hat nämlich
gesagt dass der beste langfristige und
schutz sich ergibt wenn man sich nach
drei impfungen dann mehrfach mit corona
infiziert stimmen sie dieser aussage zu
und wenn ja warum lässt man das virus
dann nicht zumindest für geimpfte
gepostete einfach lauf ja wir wollen sie
die stimme in thailand so aber wie
wollen sie das machen also die das also
sie sagen ich lasse das jetzt für die
geimpften für die gepolsterte laufen das
ist ja was zum beispiel de facto jetzt
in dänemark also auch passiert oder auch
in england passiert aber ist ja nicht
möglich also wenn ich also eine so hohe
zahl von ungeimpften habe ich kann dir
nicht das so sagen kann ich ja nicht
aussparen also das problem ist wenn ich
diese strategie verfolge dann erkranken
hat die ungeimpften schweren und das ist
das problem werden wir sie habe doch
gerade erklärt dass die ungeimpften eben
nicht schwer erkrankten zum großen
wahrscheinlichkeit die unter didier
impften lichtschwert und ich habe darauf
hingewiesen die ihr vorschlag war ja
lassen wir das noch durchlaufen wie
drosten also hier andeutet bei den
geimpften
das ist aber nicht möglich weil die
gesellschaft ist eine gesellschaft da
sind die geimpften und jungen gehen und
das heißt weil ich das so durchlaufen
lassen selbst wenn die strategie
aufgehen wir bei den also geimpften dann
würde es natürlich die umgehend volle
meter ist das nicht irgendwann auch
eigene verantwortung wenn man sich nach
so vielen jahren eben nicht impfen lässt
und dieses risiko eingeht also aus
meiner sicht ist das also
verantwortung eigene verantwortung ich
bin daher ja aus dem ich möchte einfach
nicht dass das land also immer wieder
sich der frage widmen muss was müssen
wir jetzt alles schließen welche
maßnahmen müssen wir ergreifen damit wir
erneut die ungeimpften also davor
schützen dass sie die also
intensivstationen überfüllen und die
medizinische versorgung in gefahr
bringen daher bin ich für den pflicht
ich also wir kommen aus dem dilemma
nicht heraus so lange wir eine für
europäische verhältnisse so riesige zahl
von ungeimpften haben für die wir immer
wieder so viel aufgeben müssen sie
sprechen ihre pflicht an der
lauterbacher hat sich friedrich merz
heute geäußert neuer cdu-vorsitzender
und hat gesagt dass die cdu das union
keiner der bislang vorliegenden anträge
unterstützen wird also die cdu nicht
dafür sein wird zumindest für diese
anträge das heißt doch am ende eine
mehrheit für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ab 18 oder dreifache corona info die
wackelt das jetzt zu langsam mal eine
gewissensentscheidung das ist ja keine
fraktionsentscheidung die dazu treffen
ist die disco die diskussion ist ja eine
ethische diskussion über die grundrechte
und dann stimmt jeder einzelne
abgeordnete nach seinem wissen ab
während friedrich merz also hier hingeht
und zwingt quasi gewissen hin oder her
seine fraktion also einen bestimmten
antrag also
zuzustimmen oder nicht zuzustimmen wäre
das also
schwierig also in einer solchen hoch
ethischen gewissensentscheidungen aber
dann also müsste man klarkommen ich
glaube dass auch dann bei allem respekt
vor friedrich merz und der größte der
cdu die ja auch schon mal anders im
bundestag gesessen hat also dann glaube
ich kommt trotzdem bekommen wir die
mehrheit aber friedlich mehr als
argumentiert bislang sei eben völlig
unklar wer eine impfpflicht für alle mit
welchen mitteln durchsetzen soll und was
das dann auch für arbeitsrechtliche
konsequenzen habe der sich einer solchen
pflicht widersetzt da hat er doch recht
die also anträge sind noch in der arbeit
insbesondere der antrag um die gruppe
die eine allgemeine impfpflicht 18
machen will heike behrens ja noch damit
bleiben sie dabei mit der impfpflicht ab
18 sind sie dafür ich persönlich bin
dafür das war ganz klar ich bin zwar
kein mit autor dieser dieses antrags
aber ich bin dafür ich mein wissen sie
was wie ich das hier werden wir jetzt
eine impfpflicht also machen dann muss
es auch richtiges handwerk sein dass wir
das problem erledigen werden wir eine
impfpflicht machen ich sag mal ab 55
oder eine impfpflicht für jeden zweiten
oder was auch immer dann haben wir
nachher einer riesen debatte um die
impfpflicht gehabt und das problem ist
noch immer nicht gelöst und daher denke
ich einmal sollten wir dann auch also
ein sauberes handwerk ablehnen ablegen
und in der gruppe der 18 bis 50 jährigen
sind so viele die auch schwer erkranken
können die muss ich ja auch schütz und
von daher ist das aus meiner sicht noch
immer der plausibelste also vorschlag
und was friedrich merz friedrich merz
soll einfach vorschläge machen wie ich
stellt erst lernt ja eine starke mutter
hat gesagt in einer art im vorsorge
gesetz also eine impfpflicht auf vorrat
die im fall der fälle dann schnell in
kraft treten könne ja bei allem respekt
aber wenn ich die sagen wir werden im
herbst an das kommt was jeder war es
aber wo friedrich merz noch glaubt also
dass das vielleicht nicht kommt wir
werden wieder neuer verladen also was
wird im herbst passieren im herbst oh
wunder
wir werden wieder eine welle bekommen
und dann würde mir friedrich merz mit
seinem vorschlag komme nur eine welle
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet wir
machen einen
wir setzen diesen entwurf um das würde
dann aber fünf monate dauern bis die
impfpflicht dann für die betroffenen
umgesetzt ich brauche erst die erste
impressionen da brauche ich im monat
zeit dass jeder auch irgendwo bekommen
kann dann kommt die zweite impfung dann
kommen mindestens drei monate wenn ich
das zusammenziehen ist die eben pflicht
dann abgeschlossen nach fünf monaten
wenn das jetzt mal wenn die welle jetzt
also zur überraschung einiger also man
deswegen im oktober kommt dann hätte ich
die eben fliegt dann im nächsten leben
sind sie denn bereit zu verhandeln oder
die spd-fraktion mit friedrich merz über
diesen vorschlag ich muss das ja gar
nicht also entscheidend war es ja ein
gruppenantrag ich hatte eben schon ein
paar der autoren genannt das sind ja
auch leute von der fdp aber
zum beispiel so vorher nicht klar
somit ich glaube dass wir da also ein
gut eine gute diskussion bekommen und
diese gruppe d müssen verhandeln nicht
ich bin ja nicht autor dann möchte ich
ihnen einmal zeigen was weitere
zuschauer von uns zu impfpflicht wissen
wollen andreas verwachsen aus köln hat
eine frage an sie schauen wir doch mal
nachdem das ist aktuell unser
impfspritzen reiter mit über 96 prozent
der über 18-jährigen glaube ich sind
dort mittlerweile geimpft und
gleichzeitig ist das ist dort die
hospitalisierung trat bei
12,64 also unsere spezialisierung
spitzenreiter mit weitem abstand dann
ist meine frage an sie die können dann
die mitglieder des bundestages dann
wirklich seriös über eine impfpflicht
abstimmen ja wie wollen sie das
begründen härter war also sind ja immer
also solche also selektiven statistiken
die dann zusammen gelegt dass das eine
nebenpflicht an hohe impfquoten bringt
und dass wir dann nachher also sagen wir
auch öffnungen machen können steht ja
wissenschaftlich nicht strittig das muss
ja nicht ich verteidigen sondern das
also steht unstrittigen de die frage ist
nur ob man es braucht und da bin ich der
meinung man braucht das aber das ist
wirklich druck das anders aus das die
impfpflicht wirken würde das stellt kaum
ein wissenschaftler strittig ob man sie
braucht ist eine andere frage ich glaube
wohl und in bremen beispielsweise da
sind immer sondereffekte zum beispiel
werden in bremen in der khl in kliniken
von bremen während viele menschen
behandelt die also im umland leben
und so auch die impfquote in bremen die
war immer überschätzt weil ich zähle
jede impfung also den bremen gemacht
wird aus einer impfung der bremer in
wirklichkeit kommen aber viele aus dem
umland und lassen sich in bremen ebenso
mit da muss man vorsichtig sein einzel
statistiken sind immer tricky wir haben
eine weitere frage zu impfpflicht herr
lauterbach
angenommen die in fisch kommt und wir
wären alle von games was würde sich dann
eigentlich bezüglich der sieben bands
auf der ihre ganze politik fixiert ist
was würde sich den behindern was wäre
denn wenn die ähnliche interessen hätten
die gerade zb in europa weiter
vornehmlich 3800 oder spanien 1700 was
wären dann in deutschland
es kommen wir einmal auf die variante an
und also ich versteh zuschauer so dass
er nach der mikron variante also hier
fragt weil da kann man wenn dann wenn
hohe impfquoten hat kann man trotzdem
sehr hohe instanzen sehen insbesondere
wenn es den portugal ist das also sehr
viele zweimal geimpft sind aber nicht
gewusst hat sind aber dort nicht desto
trotz muss man so sagen also werden wir
also wenn die impfpflicht umgesetzt wäre
dann wäre die wahrscheinlichkeit auch
bei hohen inzidenz
nicht gegeben oder wer nicht wirklich
dann noch nennenswert hoch dass also wir
eine überlastung gesundheitssysteme
bekämen wenn sie jetzt eben pflicht
machen man weiß doch gar nicht ob der
impfstoff den es jetzt gibt eben
tatsächlich wirkt für weitere varianten
von denen jetzt in der politik geredet
das muss natürlich in einer impfpflicht
geregelt werden dass dem pflicht gilt
für die impfstoff für deren wirkung zu
dem zeitpunkt belegt ist das ist ja klar
es gibt aber auch so bisher gibt es
jedoch ein im abo am ende wenn man sagen
also sollte ich auch noch einige andere
bedeutet ja also quasi immer mehr
impfungen der wahl die frage womit wird
geimpft also nicht also mit der frage
wie oft geimpft wird unmittelbar
korreliert somit also aber es ist ganz
klar dass wir die besten im stoffe
einsetzen werden wir werden dabei auch
die neue nikon impfstoffe von moderner
und von biotech beachten und werden bei
der impfpflicht also wenn sie kommt
wovon ich ausgehe
ein angebot machen wo derjenige sich
entscheiden kann also keiner kann also
keinen also impfstoff für alle
großes thema herr lauterbach die frage
wie jetzt bei der impfpflicht mit
krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen
umgegangen werden soll wir haben manuela
michaela bischof gefragt eine
pflegedienstleiterin ob denn ihre
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter dann
bereit sind sich auch impfen zu lassen
auf gar keinen fall weil die haben diese
entscheidung nicht ohne grund getroffen
und wenn die entscheiden das möchte ich
für mich meine gesundheit nicht dann
muss man es akzeptieren
muss man das akzeptieren natürlich also
wenn jetzt jemand in der pflege arbeitet
und sagt also ich bin von der
wissenschaftlichen auswertung der
impfstoffe nicht überzeugt und lasse
mich daher nicht impfen und also möchte
aber trotzdem da arbeiten und so das ist
also dass das kann natürlich vorgetragen
werden aber das ist natürlich nicht also
akzeptabel für den gesetzgeber und
ehrlich gesagt auch moralisch schwierig
also wenn ich in der pflege unterwegs
bin und also die die wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse die gerade konsens sind
also der gesamten westlichen welt lehne
ich ab
und bin dann aber bereit also in dem ich
nicht geimpft bin auch noch meine mir
anvertrauten patienten zu gefährden
stellt sich die frage ob ich dann
tatsächlich im richtigen beruf bin das
ist ja das ist ja dann auch eine frage
gestellt wäre was passiert mit den
menschen ganz konkret die bis zum 15
nicht gegeben sind wird es dann ohne
lohnfortzahlung mit man dann vom dienst
ausgeschlossen und muss auf dauer mit
einer kündigung rechnen daran wird
derzeit gearbeitet also wie das ganze
dann umzusetzen ist also das verfahren
ist ja bisher also wie folgt zu
beschreiben also die einrichtungen
teilen den gesundheitsämtern mit
die betroffenen sind die werden dann
angeschrieben von den also
gesundheitsämtern dann bekommt man aber
gründer geltend machen beispielsweise
also ich kann mich nicht impfen lassen
bekommt man da noch arbeitslosengeld
auch das war jetzt in der diskussion das
also sind dinge die noch zu regeln sind
und ganz klar ist also mir ehrlich
gesagt ich finde die die situation trage
ich das muss ich offen sagen wir
verdanken der pflege so viel und die
aller maßen in der pflege arbeiten dass
sich damit ganz klar sagen sind geimpft
und sind früh geimpft worden wir haben
ja wir machen jetzt die vierte impfung
sehr häufig auch bei pflegekräften war
die sich haben sehr früh impfen lassen
sie waren früh dabei bei der ersten bei
der zweiten bei der dritten jetzt sind
sie bei der vierten dabei es entsteht
hier der eindruck der vollkommen abwegig
ist ab regelt dass der größte teil der
pflegekräfte diese also sage ich mal
außenseiterposition mit vertreten oder
das ist ja nicht so und in den
pflegeeinrichtungen sind es übrigens oft
küchenkräfte oder so sagen ahlhaus was
da die da so hart dagegen stehen die
zahl der pflegekräfte nächten
pflegekräfte die da später sagen ich bin
umgeben von will es bleiben dass staaten
das steht mal dahin das glaube ich das
sind gar nicht so viele großes thema
laut aber für unsere zuschauern und
zuschauer auch die frage wie mit
genesenen umgegangen wird in zukunft
heftige diskussionen in den vergangenen
wochen um die frage sechs monate oder
drei monate ich will ihnen einmal zeigen
was karl-heinz oberhof und ein herr
schäfer zur frage beim umgang mit
genesenen zu sagen hat
wann gibt es denn endlich mal
verlässliche regeln dass man nicht immer
morgens in der zeitung liest dass das
was gestern beschlossen ist heute schon
nicht mehr gültig ist also sprich 3g
oder spricht
gepustet und dann johnson & johnson und
leute die im genom genesen sind auf
einmal kein imker kein status mehr haben
das kann es nicht sein
der grund die galater mache ich habe mal
die frage konkret wieso bei uns der
genesenen status verkürzt wird werden
auf der basis von wissenschaftlichen
ergebnissen in der schweiz und der usa
der genießen status er verlängert wird
ja zunächst einmal die also muss die
wissenschaftliche
bewertung von der politischen trennen
ich bleibe mal einfach bei der
wissenschaftlichen bewertung das
robert-koch-institut hat quasi auch
analysiert also was verändert sich jetzt
also beim genesenen status wo wir viel
mit der omicron variante zu tun haben
und dort ist die analyse zu dem ergebnis
gekommen dass eben eine stadt gehabt der
omicron variante also eine infektion mit
der stadt mit der nikon variante dass
das eben nur kurz schützt vor einer
neuen infektion zum beispiel mit einer
anderen variante und umgekehrt wenn man
mit einer anderen variante infiziert war
kann man sich relativ schnell also mit
omikron variante infizieren woher wusste
man das indem man die daten einfach
schlicht und ergreifend beispielsweise
in südafrika ausgewertet hat es gab auch
andere also daten also ich habe selbst
zwei tagen also genau ein paar studien
auf twitter gestellt also man sieht dass
tatsächlich die omikron variante dass
die gute nachricht oft leicht verläuft
aber da im rahmen dieses leichten
verlaufs also sich nur wenige antikörper
bilden bei denjenigen die ungeimpft
waren insbesondere jüngere ungeimpfte
und bei so geringen aus so sagen wir
antikörper status ist nicht damit zu
rechnen dass sie lange genesen sind dem
sinne dass sie sich nicht wieder
infizieren können und dann wiederum
andere hinten also infizieren somit also
ist das wissenschaftlich schon richtig
das robert koch institut hat für diese
verkürzung auch meines wissens nach also
in europa gekämpft dass die zahl sich
fokus aber wissenschaftlich ist aus
meiner sicht der also
der befund ganz klar der genesenen
status also eine krux ganz simpel aus
seiner armee von infektionen die nicht
tag verlaufen ist wenn man sonst noch
keine impfung oder andere infektionen
hatte die hält gerade sechs monate vor
aber sie sagen dass diese studie neben
zeigen dass gelesen dass ich nach drei
monaten wieder infizieren können aber
das gilt doch schauen sie mich hand auch
für geimpfte die frage ist doch wie
lange genesenen vor schweren fällen
geschützt sind oder wollen sie plötzlich
infektionen vermeiden also zunächst mal
werden die bohrungen stattgefunden hat
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie sich
infizieren viel geringer sie haben also
einfach pech gehabt ich eben schon sagen
sie gehören zu den 20 bis 30 prozent
pech pilzen die trotz booster impfung
sich mit angekommen infizieren das ist
so ungefähr status aber trotzdem ist es
unterschied ob ich 70 prozent schutz
habe oder gar nichts und von daher ist
das schon also die richtige lösung und
ich sag mal jetzt ich hatte eben gesagt
ich beantworte das wissenschaftlich und
politisch
politik kann man sagen damit ich die
leute jetzt nicht verwehren nicht
verwehren bleibe ich einfach bei den
sechs monaten das ist aber dann eine
knallharte politische entscheidung wo
ich dann aber weiß als wissenschaftler
dass das in wirklichkeit nicht stimmt
und ich gehe ich habe immer so es gibt
ja leute die tatsächlich auch also sich
daran orientieren was bedeutet hast du
mich also menschen die beispielsweise
jetzt ungeimpft waren haben sich mit
omikron infizierte sagen um gottes
willen für mich hat sich das impf thema
erledigt ich muss mich gar nicht mehr
impfen lassen ich habe mich jetzt mit
omikron infiziert ich war zwei tagen
erkältet und hat mich immer und jetzt
bin ich geschützt sechs monate der
genesenen status ich habe jetzt eine
sechsmonatige schutz sich da habe ich
gedacht ich muss noch zur impfung und
jetzt war jetzt erzählte ich mich jetzt
für zwei tage mit omikron und alles ist
gut es ist eben unwahr es gibt ja
wissenschaftler wie zum beispiel ein
strick der sagt man soll die gleich
behandelten geimpfte und genießen das
halte ich für also da da ist dass es
sehr steile these in dem sinne weil also
jemand der meinetwegen jetzt drei mal
geimpft ist und dass der einen ganz
anderen status hat als jemand
zwei tage an omikron also infiziert
gewesen ist also das
steht also das glaube ich nicht dritte
lassen sie uns noch einmal darüber
sprechen wie das ganze eigentlich
passiert ist und wie so viele andere
politiker ja auch auf den baum getrieben
haben also das lka hat den status der
genesenen ja fast über nacht muss man
sagen von sechs auf drei monate halbiert
wie ist das ganze wirklich passiert da
gibt es ja große diskussionen ab wann
waren sie informiert wann hat wer mit
wem gesprochen aber sag ich doch schon
auf gesagt also die auf fachebene fand
die debatte schon eine ganze zeit lang
statt so ähnlich wie sehr gerade geführt
haben und also als ich dann also im
freitags also im bundesrat und so
gesetz verabschiedet hatte zur krone
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmeverordnung
bis zu dem zeitpunkt hatte ich selbst
also an dieser debatte um die dauer des
genesenen status nicht teilgenommen also
wieder auf da wussten sie davon dass die
geführt wird und war ihre fachebene
informierte fachebene war informiert
dass die fachebene war informiert aber
ich hatte ich persönlich hatte nicht
haben sie ihr ministerium nicht im griff
die sich nicht informieren und da ich
habe ehrlich gesagt ich also da ich auch
wissenschaftler bin gehe ich ihnen sehr
viele sach diskussionen reihen also was
wo ich mir sagen lassen dass man vorhabe
vorgeht das nicht gemacht hat weil mich
einfach interessiert in dem sind also
diese debatten interessieren mich hat
aber ich arbeite hat immer ein stück
nach dem anderen ab und womit wir uns an
dem freitag beschäftigen das war ja auch
die beschlusslage ist wie wir die
isolation und die quarantäne neuen damit
hatte ich mich sehr intensiv beschäftigt
aber lasst uns jetzt bei dem eigentlich
bewusst immer wieder musste er wieder
davon ausgehen dass er sie auf ihrer
seite hat also haben sie das so
kommuniziert vorher nein das war ja also
ich wie gesagt ich hatte ja gar nicht
damit gerechnet wie ich geil aus führe
dass das an dem tag also mit auf die
seiten des robert koch instituts kommt
also sie bleiben dabei eher wieder hat
es in keiner form informiert ich bin
nicht den von mir aber das ist das habe
ich doch schon nebenbei ich muss auch
mal klar sagen das habe ich doch schon
im beisein von herrn wähler in der
bundespressekonferenz in genau gab er
weitere diskussionen darum hs will es
gibt das mal so richtig vorstellen ja
genau es gibt immer diskussionen also
ich lese da alle möglichen
räuberpistolen also ich hätte das also
angewiesen oder was auch immer so lassen
es einfach fdp-general ist eine
räuberpistole ja dass nämlich angedeutet
dass ich dann habe ich nicht gehört also
die schätze den fdp-general und habe das
von ihm nicht gehört aber aber die
menschen fragen sie herr lauterbach und
das gehört ja zur debatte dazu herr
wieder und sie da denkt man ja
eigentlich sie telefonieren relativ viel
haben wir von der tag schreiben sms
e-mails was auch immer und bei so einer
entscheidenden frage können sich viele
eben nicht vorstellen dass er wieder da
wirklich in irgendeiner form einfach
allein gehandelt haben soll ja dass das
oft dass er diesen beschluss also
auf die homepage gestellt hat und somit
wurde der ja quasi
automatisch über die verweisung zurecht
das wusste ich nicht das wird auch nicht
mehr vorkommen als dass ich damit nicht
zufrieden gewesen bin was haben sie an
wieder gesagt dass wir haben auf jeden
fall ausgesprochen aber die was klar ist
was was viel wichtiger ist ich habe das
fahren geändert und das habe ich aber
auch schon aber ich muss nochmal lassen
und nochmals ja wieder da noch immer
mehrere vor wer also vor bevor wir also
zum abend jagen und zuweisung wort ich
arbeite tatsächlich also eng mit energie
auf verschiedensten ebenen zusammen auch
mit der wähler aber nicht nur wir haben
sie auch regelmäßige treffen kann schade
und so weiter und ich habe mich ja
inhaltlich vor die der diskussion
gestellt davor die entscheidung der vor
dem beschluss gestellt aber dass das
nicht geht dass ich quasi also selbst
also wie ein bürger erfahren dass worden
dass das jetzt schon der neue status ist
und so das ist ja klar und darüber ist
offen gesprochen worden und ich habe das
verfahren hat verändert das jetzt
änderungen die also politisch relevant
sind selbst dann wenn die sachdiskussion
also geführt worden ist dass das mit mir
vorher abgestimmt sein muss und es dann
kommt der vorzug das haben wir sofort
eingeführt man muss allerdings deren
haltung gegen sagen das war auch das
erste mal dass das gesetz in dieser form
angewendet also sie stehen zu herrn
wieder viele würden sich ja fragen wenn
man so informiert und wenn das stimmt
was sie sagen warum ist er noch im amt
er hat also zwei jahre lang eine sehr
wichtige gute arbeit gemacht und genießt
weiter man vertrauen so einfach ist das
aber ich trotzdem trotzdem also sage ich
also das hier war nicht in ordnung das
wird sich auch nicht wiederholen wir
ihnen einmal denn noch mal zeigen was
der fdp-generalsekretär erzählen wieder
gesagt hat was wir gesagt haben sie
haben das nicht mitbekommen und er hat
sich sehr klar dazu geäußert und zwar
das vertrauen der fdp kann sich ja
wieder aber aufgrund dieser neuerlichen
verfehlungen die ja leider kein
einzelfall darstellt nicht mehr sicher
sein also die fdp zweifelt an händler
dann ist das eben so also ich kann nur
davor warnen
muss noch ein bisschen dankbarkeit geben
das robert-koch-institut hat zwei jahre
lang genau wie das
gesundheitsministerium eine
fantastische arbeit gemacht und also die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
arbeiten dort an der grenze der
belastbarkeit
das gilt auch für mal ein haus für das
bmw für das gesunde
bundesgesundheitskommission und da muss
sich der chef wenn es also eine wenn es
ein problem gibt also wir es hier mit
deloitte mit herrn wähler offenbar gab
muss sich der chef auch vor die behörde
vor die einrichtung stellen um die um
den wert der einrichtung zu schützen da
darf man nicht leichtfertig sagen dass
ich sicher ist aber auch dass sich das
nicht wiederholen darf jetzt hat in
osnabrück bereits in einem konkreten
fall die verfassungswidrigkeit der
kürzung des genießens status
festgestellt wie viele urteile dieser
art wollen sie da kassieren bis sie die
entscheidung des rk ii rückgängig machen
ja das ist ja was anderes also das
urteil in osnabrück betrifft nur die
frage ob dieses verwaltungsrecht also
richtig ist also dass das lka selbst
quasi entscheiden kann wie lange ist er
genießen den status wenn das ist de
facto jetzt so dass also diese aufgabe
klar gesetzt an das robert koch institut
übertragen worden ist und das ist die
rechts mechanik deren
verfassungsrechtlich kite hier geprüft
wird und also kann man unterschiedlicher
meinung zu sagen aber wir haben es ist
wir haben es mit der also mit den
ländern auch mit der fdp und so weiter
haben wir es also wir haben es ohne wir
haben es ein wir haben es beschlossen
und die länder waren dafür die fraktion
waren dafür war es geschlossen davon
unabhängig ist die frage also wie ist
das mit den drei monaten das heißt
selbst wenn jetzt diese klage durch
ginge das ist ja nur ein einziger fahrer
ein einzelfall entschieden worden in
einem also da muss man jetzt mal schauen
wie es aber selber die klage durch gänge
und der mechanismus wäre dann weg der
automatismus wäre weg dann müsste ich
das ja wieder entscheiden denn dann
müsste ich ja nur einmal sekundär dass
der bürger spricht dann müsste ich ja
rechtsverordnungen die arbeit auf mich
nehmen die quasi ich mich bestimmt das
dann uns weiter das würde ja nicht
automatisch bedeuten dass die drei
monate weg sind hat das lka zu viel
macht finde ich nicht also ich glaube
dass das rk ii in einiger hinsicht also
auch international
als vorbildlich betrachtet wird beachtet
wird und ich habe eben schon gesagt also
womit wir grad durch die mikrowelle
fahren also mit dem modell des aks das
ist so dass das sucht seinesgleichen von
daher man darf jetzt also mache ich
jedes falsch das rkw klein oder schlecht
zu reden das ist eine einrichtung um die
wir international beneidet werden herr
lauterbach zum abschluss unseres
gesprächs will ich noch mal darauf
eingehen was wir morgen fordern sie mir
bereits gesagt sie wollen das nicht sie
sind dagegen anders als bild ab wann
sagen sie ist reicht
wie lange muss das dauern ein jahr zwei
jahre drei jahre wann die wanne ist
genug ich glaube
wenn es wirklich gut läuft dann wird es
wie folgt laufen wir kriegen die
mikrowelle in den griff die fallzahlen
sinken wir lockern wir haben das aber
dann so gemacht dass wir eine deutlich
geringere zahl von sterbefällen und
schwerstkranken gab dann alles wie sonst
artet das muss ja auch erklärt werden
war der bürger denkt was soll das alles
wofür machen dass wir haben ja auch
erfolge im ausland sieht man die erfolge
die wir haben zum teil sehr viel klarer
weil in vielen anderen ländern hat man
diese sterbeziffer nicht und wenn wir im
herbst dann tatsächlich eine impfpflicht
bekämen dann glaube ich ist der spuk
vorbei war das geht weil wir damit also
die impflücken geschlossen und sie sagen
im herbst ist der spuk vorbei bedeutet
das dann auch ein ende der massenflucht
das also steht dahin aber es wird
wirklich davon abhängen davon bin ich
fest überzeugt ob er die eben pflicht
schaffen oder nicht also aus ihrer sicht
hängt die masken fliegt an der
impfpflicht die maske will ich jetzt
nicht da alleine also ob wir wirklich im
herbst wieder in eine problematische
situation kommen wo dann vieles
diskutiert wird welche maske womit wir
zu machen was machen denn den
restaurants und so werden wir uns diese
diskussion für den herbst ersparen
wollen und auch unseren kindern übrigens
sind die schulen auf und so brauchen wir
die impfpflicht wie oft herr lauterbach
träumen sie positiv wie oft machen sie
morgens positiv auf man hat manchmal das
gefühl sie sehen eben viele gefahren
aber nicht so ganz das licht ich sehe
ich gesagt das licht ganz klar ich habe
sogar noch gesagt wir kommen gut durch
diese mikrowelle besser als andere
länder und wir werden im herbst also
wenn wir eben pflicht durch bekommen
haben werden wir das gröbste hinter uns
haben im herbst ist der spuk vorbei
haben sie gesagt herzlichen dank karl
lauterbach herzlichen dank dass sie sich
immer wieder stellen und das war es mit
den richtigen fragen mit
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach
[Musik]